had a bigger influence on how to take
Epstein's game to the next level was it
gelaine because what she learned from
her father or was it something that apps
like who brought more to the table for
the crime that they committed both of
them together was it more Epstein's
background or was it more killings
experience well uh you mean after Robert
Maxwell's death yes so I think Elaine
was looking to continue the same role
she was sort of doing for her Father
which was being an ambassador for her
father basically in New York and the
interests that represented him his
handlers sort of looked to her and at
this time Jeffrey Epstein is is the
money manager for Leslie Wexner
and Leslie Wexner is affiliated with a
group of very powerful
um billionaires who at the same time
that Robert Maxwell made his inroads to
New York with galane sort of his
um uh the Ambassador
um oh sorry I lost my train oh yeah um
they're quoted in I think Vanity Fair of
having core those billionaires courting
Robert Maxwell specifically so it seems
like there was some sort of effort to
bring those interests together even
before Robert Maxwell died this name Les
Wexner if you're not familiar with it I
mean go ahead and tell I mean this is
Victoria's Secret this is the guy that
basically created the modern day
shopping mall Abercrombie and Fitch
Victoria's Secret like reveal a little
bit about this okay so I mean he he's a
retail guy so I guess the big Brands
we're familiar with yeah he's the one
that backs them but he his rise to power
is partly linked to
um people that CR that built the
shopping malls and the least space to
him they called him the Merlin of the
mall something of that yeah think that's
a nickname for for waxner yeah but
people like Edward de Bartolo I think is
how you pronounce de Bartolo they own
the 49ers I mean this is all coming
together these were yeah yeah all the
money ladies and gentlemen yeah keep
going yeah and then Alfred Taubman who
was another big shopping he built a lot
of shopping malls he's one of the guys
that really he's considered a mentor to
Wexner asses Max Fisher and these are
guys really powerful people from Detroit
specifically involved in real estate
shopping mall stuff Max Fisher also has
a background in oil but also got into a
lot of well he's the guy that made
Taubman I guess because Todman built a
lot of I think the gas station like
convenience stores for the oil company
and then got into retail uh commercial
centers and the reason I was about Lex
Wexner is because I went down the rabbit
hole you've done multiple interviews
with Tim Dylan right I loved Tim I know
like uh he's uh someone that we're
entity
he'll be he'll be here pretty soon but
I've watched multiple of your interviews
and Tim Dillon you know multiple
connections there but you said quote
unquote Epstein made his money from
links to three powerful men and you said
Les Wexner you said Bill Gates and then
you said Donald Trump that's not for me
that's a 2001 article from the evening
standard which is a mainstream media
publication in the UK prestigious right
and it's never been retracted it's from
2001 but if you believe U.S mainstream
media Bill Gates and Epstein didn't meet
till 2011 and this is 2001. so there's
10 years of there's more than 10 years I
think with Bill Gates and Epstein yeah
gotcha it's pretty crazy that there's an
article like that out there from 2001
and mainstream media is like 2011. what
did that article say
uh well it's it's talking so that
evening standard article is talking
mainly about prince Andrew and who are
Prince Andrew's new friends oh it's
Elaine Maxwell because obviously you
know Robert Maxwell's theft of the
pension fund money obviously had huge
ramifications in Britain a lot of people
uh for understandable reasons didn't
like the Maxwell family after that so a
lot of the gossip columns or newspapers
report a lot on what the Maxwell
children were doing they sort of became
Infamous celebrity children you know and
so they follow up on them and then
prince Andrew you know Circa 2000 or so
is going on vacation after vacation with
Colleen Maxwell and Jeffrey Epstein and
so Jeffrey Epstein is sort of introduced
in that article and they're trying to
explain to Their audience in Britain in
2001 who Epstein is because people
probably haven't heard of them yeah they
all know galane they all do prince
Andrew obviously but they don't know
Jeffrey Epstein so the introduction to
Jeffrey Epstein is he's uh they describe
him as a property developer and actually
a lot of early articles on Epstein don't
say a billionaire financial advisor like
a lot of the later ones do they say
property develop upper there's a real
estate connection there which is I sort
of explore and then in that article
what's the gates Trump connection with
all that's what they say the line there
is that this is where you know Jeffrey
Epstein's money comes from these are his
clients his top clients basically and so
people know that there was a
long-standing Wexner relationship a
long-stinning trump relationship but it
mentions Bill Gates and at the time Bill
Gates never challenged that article you
know it was never retracted like I
mentioned earlier the UK has very strong
libel laws if it was untrue he could sue
and it could be retracted today but it's
never been done so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]